[Music]
Do
n't
you dare Ohta, you're the one who fixed the fish I can't read at all
.
Mt. Akagi, a
tourist attraction, because it's stored in a
round mushroom mountain
Why is
it called cannibalism?
The
real name of the blue crab that crosses is thrown
away.The purpose of going to Mihama
is touring.
It doesn't
seem like it happened, so what's the story
?
Until the day is red, do
n't be silly.The only way for
criminals to escape from Gunma
is through the desert and into Mihama from this southern
checkpoint.  I don't know
when the bounty bosses will
pass by I
want a graveyard full of cannibals I want
a world after death
If we go together, we won't be afraid If it's
bright and early
Two is all  I
'm doing it,
sleep wrapped up,
right? It's a
vigilante group.
Is
it a workbench?
I went out to
see a customer who was a left-winger, so he said he didn't have enough money,
so he gave me a toy
doll.
Look, it's in front of the building
, so it
seems like it's really hidden.  There's a sharp black
stick standing up, isn't it? It's so big, and it's
bent like this,
like raising a sickle neck
.
That's the iron man who cursed you,
is
n't it?
But Ian and the others
[music] I can't
hold back anymore I'm such a sudden child
Ah, it
's okay It doesn't hurt, so it's fine for people who have a little pain,
but
this will bring down the fever.
Please take a look first
Okay, then sit here, uh
, it's proof that you've been a good girl who didn't give up your faith. I'll give you
an injection.
But
I don't care about that kind of expensive medicine. With
that ampoule, I can only slow down the progress of rust a little.
So, let's go through next time Okay,
if you're definitely going to get caught, even if you get caught, you'll
put out my name
.  If it's a year, then
there are a lot of guys who want to bring it to the savior rice and wear it in the palm of their hands
.
Look, I've been staring at Tetsujin's finger for a while, and when I take a
closer look, there's a strange man standing beside that finger.
I wonder how much it would cost to sell
it?
That's it.  everyone  Thank you,
look, teacher,
play around with the basics, and if it's a 9-round system, it's free hot water
, I've got a bottle of air, I
'm happy, but I'm happy, but my sister is waiting for me at home, so
it's the same
in a city like this  No, I
don't do business with the rich people at the prefectural office through a well-done strike
.
The chorus wind is especially strong, so be careful
Then
call me Cola-sensei for a live performance
Okay, O
-sensei, you're late today,
aren't you?
Doru
: I'm
feeling good I want to feed you while I'm still healthy
That's the best thing The
teacher's looking at me, and it's my home's
monjuque What a sickness that can't be cured, Alesia.
Do you have any
miso sandwiches today?  Sensei,
I don't really know you either.
My daughter's
free day Please come back when you run out of medicine The
usual mutated gori for water It's a
medley
From the beginning of June
Gifu Prefecture's academic exam
followed by the Gunma exhibition The mushroom teru that continues continuously
seems to be a crime by the same criminal
Meaning  The Hama Prefectural Office
had asked the Gunma Prefectural Police to provide information on the terrorists, but the Gunma Prefectural Office announced
today that
terrorists were constantly killed in Gunma Prefecture.
I'm a
bit late to see this,
so I was worried.
[Music]
Please experiment
again I got the liver of a lead shark
I thought it would be a good material for new medicines, so the
prefectural government gave me the latest dispensing machine.
I know that if I owe too much, I'll be in trouble.
But if I could make a rust remedy with this dispensing machine, I'd be able
to help not only Pow, but everyone who suffers from rust.
I
'd like
to try it
What kind of material was it
?  If you play a bow
, even if it's earth or steel, it
'll hit the spot.A mushroom like a big
tree will get in. An outrageous tree is also an advantage.
I'm not going to heal a villain who got away from another prefecture
because I
'm going to touch your class.
In addition, I have a rough sketch of what the package will fit in Ah
Ah Ah
[Music]
Notice
wh Is this already for you? Please take a look.
On the other hand, Gunma Prefecture has just announced that the terrorist Akahoshi Bis has
already been killed because of his kuma habit, and
it is strongly believed that the teaching information was intentionally long.  It's
a plan to protest, isn't
it
?  Ikemiro It seems that the
terrorists just entered the Saitama Iron Desert The
five terrorists, Akahoshi, who are only cannibals Recently, the
thugs who are causing trouble all over Japan Will they be able to cross the wall of the beach
?  The government is called a government, and
the strongest poison becomes the strongest good medicine.As a result, when I was in my 21s, as
long as I had a point, even my family could easily make the
strongest question.
I wanted to add one stallion  Thank you
for your help
[music]
ana
b
[music]
b Behold the Day
A man who hits a woman is the worst.
After all
, what did the executive see just now?
Come on,
tell me what
are you doing? There's a needle in the
puncture wound.  It
's next to the hardware store on the right
, and I'm afraid I'm sorry.
The whole school is
nothing
more than a red sea bream game like a rich man throwing pickled cheeseburgers at my dog
I
can't say, no, I can't say that I'm managing the corrections myself and say that it's a
salty town.  Is the machine useful? Take
care of the merchandise and equipment.
If so,
which one is useless? Will you
argue about the funniest manga while picking nuts with me?
If you don't have money, you can't do anything about it.The
previous one is the key.You've been miserably bullied in this
town.Work at the
prefectural office NekoyanagiWith your skills,
you can buy an amplifier with a service that allows you to get as much money as you want from outside the prefecture.
My
older sister also has a lotus cup, and
she piles up
corpses.
Phew Mushio 4 I've
got a centipede biting me in the
chain.If I hit it in the sun, it'll go
wild.I'll even tear my fingers off
.
It's not done, I know,
isn't that
what projectiles are for?
tar
This is a video of the main street from the current time.As you can see, this month I was
terrorized after the day by Mushroom Forest.I feel that everyone in the prefecture is unnecessary.
It's amazing, just like it came from A big mushroom for a moment
Pow No, the same medicine hasn't finished yet It
seems like it's going to reach the depths,
but work is more important than life You are important, Milo, hold the
key until you return  The one who should
n't leave here must
be powder.
I won't put it on, no matter
what happens, even
if I ask you to do the same, there was a time when I asked you to move away, and the pow broke
I'm the same
I've never heard of an older sister feeding her younger brother.
I don't think I can make the material I'm a
processing stone I
'm a cannibal but I
want a grave
na na na
[applause]
rar ah ah ah
[music]
rar
me
ah ah ah
bejean
[applause]
[music]
[music] The
wind turns civilization into paper-opener sand
Only one rusts your gaze
Kanamaru,
next time Yuri's older brother will eat away at destruction, Tobei Ishikon